hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
moves section on move university comm
thank you and enjoy now let me discuss
the overview of how glycerophospholipids
are made I want to consider how the head
group is actually being added on so
please just consider this we have
diacylglycerol phosphoric acid and some
alcohol that will be attached to the
polar head group these three things have
to come together to make the
glycerophospholipid which you can
imagine is that there will be a
dehydration reaction here where that
water will come off and it'll link those
two components there'll be a dehydration
reaction here that would link those two
components and then we have our
glycerophospholipid right now the issue
is that these three components cannot
simply come together like this
one of the groups is that the diacyl
glycerol or the head group must be
activated first now the question might
be okay which one actually needs to be
activated the dice of whistle or the
polar head group alcohol and the answer
is that either can either can be
activated and this is the reason there
are two methods for actually adding the
head group to to make the
glycerophospholipid so let's take a look
we've got method one which will
basically be from starting from an
activated diacylglycerol and then method
two which would be from the activated
alcohol so let's take a look at method
one first so method one we have an
activated diacylglycerol the activated
ice of withdrawal is actually this thing
right here this entire molecule this is
called the CDP daj so here you can see
the dice of withdrawal portion here
right this part here that's the dice of
glycerol portion and the rest of this
here actually let me maybe do it like
this this part here is the
diacylglycerol portion and the rest of
this including these two phosphates is
the CDP portion from the nucleotide
right so this here is cytosine this
little portion here
that's Luca tied base cytosine right and
those the DP the diphosphate portion
there now when this CDP is attached to
the dye use of whistle roll the dice of
whistle roll is considered activated so
this is the activated diacylglycerol
so this polar head group over here this
polar head group alcohol here is going
to join this activated diacylglycerol
and actually be nucleophilically attack
at this phosphate portion here attack
that phosphate thus kicking off this
this love these electron pairs here on
to the oops onto this oxygen okay and
then we have a cmp that leaves and then
this alcohol portion will be connected
to this phosphate so when as up
happening is that's that cmp portion
leaves and then we're left with a
glycerophospholipid or the
diacylglycerol portion and the
phosphates are connected to this polar
head group alcohol okay
now you might be wondering okay that's
great and that makes sense but how did
we even get the CDP daj thing how did we
activate this isoh glycerol here what we
did was we started with phosphate a date
floss for today and we invested a CTP
and foster today it has no phosphate on
it
CTP has three so that's four phosphates
that we start off with okay and then we
have CDP d AG so it's two phosphates
there right two phosphates there and
that's it what are the other two
phosphates go they came off as a
pyrophosphate will see the details of
this later okay in that in the following
videos in the series but that that's
basically the idea here is that we
started from the activated
diacylglycerol and the alcohol acted as
the nucleophile
now method two doesn't start with an
activated day so glycerol and instead
starts from an activated alcohol so
instead of creating a CDP d AG we create
a CDP alcohol so again same idea here
this portion we have the cytosine a
portion here the CDP here up in two with
the including these two phosphates
and then we've got the alcohol here so
now this is the activated alcohol this
is the activated alcohol and over here
this diets of glycerol is free so what's
going to happen is that the base of
whistles oh age group here watch is the
nucleophile attack this phosphate oops
that's kind of an ugly arrow let's do
that again it'll attack this phosphate
kicking off
electrons and kicking off a CMP so the
CMP will fall off again to give us a
list real phospholipid so again you
might ask how do we get that CDP alcohol
in this case it was a little bit
different how we got it not quite the
same way as as how we got the CDP dyes
of glycerol you start with the polar
head group alcohol and we invest ATP
with a kinase invest ATP with a kinase
and that that bought one of those
phosphates gets attached to the polar
head group so we get a polar head group
with a phosphate group attached to it
and then ADP is left over once we have
that CTP can be invested and then the
polar head group that has the CDP
portion attached to it with two
phosphates and a pyrophosphate leaves
again the details of which will make a
little bit more sense in the following
videos but in either way in either case
either method gives us the same molecule
glycerophospholipid one thing to mention
is how this occurs in eukaryotes are
prokaryotes in eukaryotes both methods
are possible whereas in prokaryotes only
method one can occur so that's something
that we'll investigate in the next two
videos hope that video was helpful thank
you for watching thanks for watching
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
and be sure to share the video with
anyone who you think might find helpful
thanks and happy studying